>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Could I
have your attention please?
We're going to start the second
half of our Literacy Conference.
So I hope you all enjoyed your
lunch and I'm happy to report
that we are on schedule now.
So thank you for your patience.
Okay. Our next panel
is developing
and sustaining readers
across the lifespan.
And our moderator for this
panel is Joshua Cramer
who is the Vice President
of the National Center
for Families Learning
which was also a Library
of Congress Literacy
Awards winner.
Thank you, Joshua.
[ Clapping ]
>> Joshua Cramer: Hello,
good afternoon everybody.
This is kind of a tough
gig right after lunch.
[Laughter] And also you don't
know it till you get up here
but there aren't any clocks.
So hopefully we can keep this
on schedule but thanks a lot,
Guy, for -- [inaudible].
So I'll be looking down
occasionally but first,
let's start by just giving
another round of applause
for this morning's panelists.
[ Clapping ]
And as a fellow panel leader,
I have to commend especially
the second panel who found a way
to add 45 additional minutes.
So hopefully we won't have
to do that but we'll see.
My name's Josh Cramer and I
have the opportunity to serve
as the Vice President
of the National Center
for Families Learning.
And today we're going
to have a discussion
around how we could develop
and sustain readers
across a lifespan.
And lucky for you, you
don't have to listen to me
for the entire 45 minutes.
I have with me a very
talented panel of individuals
who have lived and worked in
this space for many, many years.
And also I might add, all
have this common thing
of an entrepreneurial spirit
and I hope some of that comes
across in our discussion.
Before we get into the real
meat of what it means to develop
and sustain readers
across a lifespan,
I wanted to talk just
briefly about NCFL.
It truly is an honor
to wake up each morning
and read our mission statement
that says that we are trying
to eradicate poverty
by leveraging family
based education solutions.
And our President and founder,
Sharon Darling, 30 years ago,
discovered through her work as
an adult literacy instructor
in Kentucky and in
specifically in Appalachian,
Eastern Kentucky, that in order
to truly get at the root issues
of helping families
climb out of poverty,
we had to build both
adult literacy skills
and child literacy skills, and
bring them together to learn.
And luckily what she found out
through her own cardiac research
or what she knew was right in
her heart has been confirmed
through three decades of
research now that we can look to
and performance that tells us
that family literacy is truly
a way to make great gains
for the families who
need it the most.
This is what gets me
out of bed every morning
and it really is the
root of developing
and sustaining readers
across a lifespan.
At NCFL, we know that
the genesis of reading
and literacy happens the moment
that a child hears her mother
or father or caregiver
say words to them.
And hopefully that's
through reading.
From there, we reinforce
those activities and we hope
that by creating
that intergenerational
reading experience,
that we create lifelong learners
for all children and families.
And here today, we've heard
many of the dire statistics
about low literacy,
illiteracy, and the things
that those horrible parts
of our society bring as far
as putting barriers in place
for families to be successful.
And that's something we're
very concerned about at NCFL
but I didn't want to focus
more on the topic of reading
which is one way we
practice literacy, of course.
And we all know that reading
builds background knowledge
and it helps us learn and we
can actually access society
through the process
of reading but some
of the other things I was
interested to find out --
some of you probably know this.
But reading regularly
can reduce stress.
It can keep your brain
sharp until later adulthood.
There are even a few studies
that say it may protect
against dementia in older
adults by 3 to 7 years.
Just reading throughout
a lifetime.
You sleep better when
you read regularly.
It increases empathy which
was mentioned before.
And I think that's
something that's very serious
at this point in our society.
We could definitely benefit
from some more empathy.
It can ease depression.
And my personal favorite
that I found
in my quick research was it can
actually cultivate your ability
to read minds.
[Laughter] So just
imagine what a group
of literacy professionals
can do when we learn how
to read minds better and
get people to do what it is
that we want them to do.
So with that, we're going to go
ahead and begin our discussion.
And our first panelist
here directly to my left,
you have their full bios in
your program is Mike McGuffee
who is the CEO of
Unite For Literacy.
We have Louise Baigelman,
the Co-Founder
and Executive Director of Story
Shares, Christopher Lehman,
Founding Director of the
Educator Collaborative,
and Dustin Holland, Vice
President of Better World Books.
So I think my microphone
works if I sit down here.
When we talk about
reading and developing
and sustaining readers
across a lifespan,
of course we're beginning in the
youngest years as I mentioned.
And Mike, I would like to
just start with you talking
about your work and what
you think is most important
in the early years.
>> Mike McGuffee: So we
have been doing this work --
I've been doing this
work forever.
Maybe about three decades
and I've done a lot
of work in Indian country.
And what I realized
in doing that work was
when I felt was the fundamental
problem was access to books
which then I developed
a formula just
like Stephen [phonetic] thinking
about what is the formula
for this and we look at this now
as a problem that's
-- it's three parts.
It's -- it is access but
you also have to have access
to relevant books and
then that's not enough.
You have to have engagement
around those books.
So it's access, relevance,
and engagement
to me is the way I frame a
problem and think about it.
And with access, our company
has developed a definition
for what we consider to be
the deserts or book scarcity.
We've actually mapped
the United States
down the census track using NAP
[phonetic] data and census data.
And we think that 75% of
the United States has homes
with less than 100 books.
And that's a staggering number
and we're actually rebuilding
our map so that we can see --
so that you working in your
communities can interact
with that map.
The next thing is relevance.
And there's lots of ways
to think about relevance
but one is there's more than
200 languages that are spoken
in the United States,
indigenous and immigrant.
And so we need to figure out
how to create greater relevance.
So in our library, we
have an online library
for emergent readers essentially
and we write the books
in English but we
also narrate them.
Right now, our narrations are
getting close to 40 languages.
We're doing a project with
the [inaudible] River Indian
Community South of Phoenix
where they're writing books
that celebrate their
culture and language.
Over a four year
period, we're trying
to write 100 little
emergent books with them.
And then we're trying to
get 100 of those books
into the homes across
the community.
So relevance is an
important piece.
And then last is engagement.
And it's one thing to get
books into kids' homes
but it's another
thing to inspire them
to become lifelong readers.
And we find that is really
challenging for us to think
about the -- we talked --
this morning about a culture
of literacy, a culture
of reading.
It's nurturing a
culture of reading
in the communities
where we work.
So that engagement
piece is really --
has really been interesting
to us.
We looked at NAP data and
found something amazing.
The interesting thing
about NAP is
that they have been
surveying kids forever
with two questions
that we found useful.
One they ask how many books
do you have in your home?
And two, they ask how often
do you choose to read for fun?
And when you take those two
questions and analyze them,
what we found was that
if you have 0 to 10 books
and you never read, about 7% of
that population is proficient
in reading in the eighth grade.
When you have 100 books and you
have a daily habit of reading,
about 70% of those kids are
proficient and the pattern
across that as you add books,
it improves but you have
to have books and reading.
People say to me all the time,
it has to be more than books.
And the answer is yes, it is
more than books because it has
to be that those kids read them.
So when we look at the
kids that have 100 books
and they say never read.
Their scores aren't that great
but when they have 100 books
and they read everyday
it matters.
So we've looked at this and
kind of made our formula
about access, relevance,
and engagement.
The last thing is for when we
think about sustaining readers
across a lifetime, I
think we have to look
at our educational system as
a complex adaptive system.
We have to look at
this as a system
and Donnelle Meadows [phonetic]
who's a great system --
was a great systems thinker
said if you really want
to impact the system, you
got to look at the purpose.
And not what the
stated purpose is,
what's the behavior
of the system?
What I think is going on is that
we have to have a higher purpose
in our system than
grade level reading.
We have to have a higher
purpose in our system
than kindergarten readiness.
And actually the title
of our talk is probably
a much greater purpose.
What would happen if our
educational system thought
about this and said how do we
sustain readers over a lifetime?
What if we measured that?
What if we really thought about
how do you get kids excited
about reading and
keep them reading?
So how do we think
about it is start early.
And we think Frank Smith
once said it's this simple.
Get a book in a kid's hands that
they want to read and can read
and when they finish
get another.
So in some ways,
it's that simple.
In the complex way, it's we've
got to look at our schools,
our communities as systems,
and starting having more
of a systems perspective.
>> Joshua Cramer: Thanks, Mike.
And Louise, if I can I
would like to ask you
and probably Chris as well just
to move us along the lifespan
and talk a little bit about
the middle school grades,
the high school grades, what are
those things that we could do
to sustain and develop readers?
>> Louise Baigelman: Yeah.
So thank you so much
for having me here.
It's an honor to be here.
Again, I'm Louise Baigelman.
I am the former literacy
specialist and English
as a Second Language teacher
and now I run an organization
called Story Shares.
We're focused on teen readers.
So the students that have
kind of gotten beyond the age
where we're typically focused
on reading instruction still
reading below grade level.
Those who struggle
with reading, you know,
in late elementary school,
middle school, high school,
and I'm actually going to touch
on a lot of the very same things
that Mike just talked about and
also that came up this morning
but as they apply to the teen
reader phase of the lifespan.
So with engagement being
really the key piece to if --
you know, we all
know that in order
to become a stronger reader, you
have to read and that in order
to read meaningfully,
to actually read deeply,
and make meaning from text,
you have to be engaged
with the reading.
And so the key factors that
play to that engagement are
as Mike said relevance
and also choice.
And I know that came up a
lot this morning as well.
So we need to be able to provide
teen readers who are struggling
with reading with books
that they can connect to.
Books that are culturally
relevant for a diverse,
wide range of readers where
they can really see themselves
reflected in the books
that they're reading.
And books that are relevant
to their age and interests.
So books where they can
read about other characters
who are their own age, who are,
you know, dealing with things
that they're dealing with.
And then choice which again
came up a lot this morning.
That it's one of the biggest
factors in reading meaningfully
and that a huge number
of students report
that they cannot
find enough books
that they actually like to read.
And so these, you know, two
pieces, relevance and choice,
become actually, you know,
a unique challenge on a lot
of levels when you look at
the teen reader audience
that is struggling
because if you are 12 or 16
and you're reading at a
first or a third grade level,
you're never going to be
excited by books written
for first or third graders.
Books that are written
for elementary school
students are never going
to be interesting to you.
Not only will they be boring
and kind of totally irrelevant
to the things you're working on
and thinking about in your life
but also embarrassing to
read in front of your peers.
And so, you know,
how do we address
that piece of the problem?
How do we provide enough choices
that these students can find
that they can like to read
whether it's late elementary
school, middle school,
or high school or beyond.
And, you know, we know that
it's a huge number of students
who fit into this category.
It's tens of millions
in this country alone.
So this problem just from a
personal standpoint is one
that I experienced as a teacher.
I was a middle school teacher
in Lynn, Massachusetts.
And most of my teaching
as English
as a Second Language
as I mentioned.
Most of students were from the
Dominican Republic or Haiti
and they were, you
know, sassy and witty
and mature middle
school students but a lot
of them were reading at first
and second grade levels.
And one of my biggest
challenges was, you know,
access to choices for them.
Even as the teacher who is
actively pursuing options
that I could offer them
that would engage them
in reading so that they'd read.
So that they'd improve.
I just couldn't find enough
books to offer a range
of choices that they
would want to read
and that they could read.
And so, just to touch briefly
on Story Shares and what we do.
We are focused on
finding kind of new ways
to generate more choices.
More of these books
that are relevant
to older students
aged interests,
culturally relevant for
diverse, you know, learners,
that are accessible and
approachable in both format
and also language at a range
of much lower reading levels.
And so doing, giving
readers books that will kind
of hook them and give them
the positive associations
with reading that we all have
and kind of help to erase some
of those negative ones.
And so what we do
is we actually tap
into the community of writers.
We crowd source these
books by providing --
we do an annual writing
contest and we provide guidance
and incentives and an awareness
campaign to get writers
and educators to contribute to
this new collection of books
to submit their own stories.
And then we use those stories.
We curate them and have them
become part of the collection.
And again, what we -- you
know we all know to be true is
that when we can find that
experience with a book,
that spark of something that
starts with what we love,
what we care about already,
what we connect with,
whether it's you know,
baseball or food or gossip.
That we can start to really --
sometimes it literally just
takes the one book to realize
that this is not something --
you know it's not
that I'm not a reader.
It's just that I hadn't -- as
come up, I haven't found books
that really speak to me.
And so what we see
and what we know is
that once we can offer
these students choices
that are meaningful to
them that they can read,
that kind of destigmatize
their experience with reading,
not only are they reading
more but also they're talking
about the books that
they're reading more.
You know we love hearing from
teachers about, you know,
you read a new book and then
this is a student who's maybe
so reluctant and has
struggled so much with reading,
after they have an experience
with the book that they love,
they say could we
talk about this?
You know I want to tell
you about what I read.
And also can I have
other books like this?
And not only do they
inspire students to read more
but also to actually to write.
We know that sometimes
you can be so inspired
by something you've
read that you even want
to kind of write your own.
Whether it's an adaptation
of that
or something inspired
by or a sequel.
And so kind of focusing
on generating
and distributing more books
that are really relevant
to a wide range of students
while also being approachable
to really hook them and then set
them on path of being readers.
>> Joshua Cramer:
Thanks, Louise.
Chris?
>> Christopher Lehman: And
what Louise and I were talking
about this conversation,
one thing we also touched
on was just the shame
that can come
for you being an adolescent
reader who is carrying
around a book that's Judy Moody
or something that's not
appropriate for your age level.
And that's both from the
community that you build
or don't have in your classroom
but that affects the
child as well too.
So I come to this
conversation from K12 pedagogy.
That's been my experience
nearly working on two decades
of working as a classroom
teacher
and then supporting
educators as well.
I'm also honored to serve
on the board with NCFL.
And so one conversation
that we often have at NCFL
with the education work group
that we support with them
and just in my work in general,
at the secondary level is
just looking at this pattern
that continues to play out
where there's kind of two things
that happen at the same time.
One is we see this slump in
test scores or in performance
when kids hit middle school
where students are growing,
growing, growing across the
elementary years and then
when we hit secondary there's
like something happens.
And so many districts have
questions around that.
You equally like
with the NAP data,
Common Sense Media organization
has also done some surveys,
longitudinal surveys
around this as well.
You see students at the
same time reporting out.
You can almost correlate
them against each other
that as there's a slump
in secondary performance,
there also are kids who
are reading less and less
as you move up through years.
And so I say this with love
because I'm an educator myself
and I love the field
that we're in.
One challenge for the
literacy community to look at
and address is that -- to really
be partners with and support
around is that any teacher
and the vast majority
of teachers are working
hardest with so little and with
so much negative attention from
the press and everywhere else.
But every teacher is using to
their best of ability the tools
and knowledge that
they already have.
And there's a tremendous gap
in both professional learning
for teachers of high quality
and in pre-service
teacher education programs
around literacy specifically
especially
at the secondary level.
So what you have are
teachers who are often times
with their full heart
teaching in the way
that they remember being taught
when they were a kid whether
that worked for them and
their fellow peers or not.
And often times, it doesn't.
And so one challenge we have is
around choice is also moving
ahead the conversation
around practice at
the second level.
We know from numerous
school sites and districts
that independent reading at this
level is booming and beautiful
and can grow an entire
communities.
And really shift everything
from test scores to how students
and families feel about school.
The challenge is there
are so many classrooms
and so many progress through
all those grade levels
that become based on
just single books.
So Penny Kiddle who's
an educator and writes
for the Educator, she
often says, you know,
here we are especially at this
time right now where there's
such a boom of middle grade
and young adult literacy
where we are surrounded
by this endless library
of incredible books.
Here we are at the
Library of Congress.
This incredible library of
amazing books and too often
in our pedagogical practices, we
boil those down to four or five,
one perhaps that we all
have to read together.
And whether that matches your
reading level or your relevance
or you care about it or not,
this is what we'll do together.
So one place that we can really
work is to take the research
and energy that we all have
in this room and beyond,
and continue to tell the
story of these practices
with our older students
and with educators
at upper levels as well.
And also to consider if
your program focuses more
specifically at younger grades,
so much of your practices
translate up.
It really is the types
of texts that you use
but the practices are
inherently the same.
That really is a place that
your organization can look.
Can we support older students?
We absolutely can because
it's kind of the same work.
Then equally that's
one area to focus.
Another that feels important
because of where we are
and because we can see
Congress if we just look
out that window right
there is just to echo --
I really appreciated Dr. --
I mean I appreciate
everything Dr. [inaudible] does.
It was just awesome
to be in the same room
but his earlier comments around
poverty, poverty, poverty.
I think we also have to lay
that what goes above that,
the kind of larger capsule
over poverty, poverty,
poverty is just the
systemic oppression, racism,
the way that our society allows
some people to reach poverty,
and some people not to.
And some classrooms to be
funded and some not to.
So one thing that our
organization works really hard
to do and just want to
suggest as something for all
of our organizations to
continue do or to consider
if we don't already, whether
you're non-profit or public,
is when our families and
students are in jeopardy
or in need, we have
to find a message
and support around that as well.
Because we can support a
reader who is deported.
We can't support a reader
who's family is not allowed
into the country because
of their religion.
We can't support a reader
who doesn't feel safe
in their classroom because
they have a food shortage.
And one thing that we've
done in our organization,
the Educator Collaborative,
and continue do is really
first working on our approach
and the way that we enter
communities but also to continue
to speak out when our students
and families need those too.
So thinking about when is the
time to talk, it was probably
like 10 years ago but
when things come up,
that's another form
of supporting our secondary
learners is making sure
that we're supporting their
safety and their livelihoods
and their family's
safety as well.
>> Joshua Cramer: Thanks, Chris.
Dustin, one of the themes
that we've heard today
and in other conversations
around reading
across a lifespan is the
importance of book availability.
And I know this is something
that you care deeply about.
So if you could speak just a
little bit to book availability
and how that impacts
reading across the lifespan.
>> Dustin Holland: Yeah, sure.
Thanks, Josh.
And first, I'd like to
thank everybody in the room
for what you're doing to
promote lifelong learning
and especially creating
our future customer base.
So we really appreciate it.
But at Better World Books
we believe in the power
of knowledge and our purpose
is to share and distribute
that knowledge around the world.
And my personal goal is to
collect over a billion books
and keep a billion
books out of landfills
and keep them in
the reuse cycle.
So to date, we've kept over 300
million books out of landfills
in about six countries.
We've sold over 75 million
books and shipped those books
to customers in over
200 countries.
Along the way, we've been able
to donate 25 million books
to countries all over the world,
organizations all
over the world.
Some of you in this room
have been recipients
of either book donations
or monetary donations.
We just recently hit the
$27 million mark in terms
of money that's been donated
to literacy organizations
or libraries around the world.
So we're really proud of what
we do at Better World Books.
Our 500 employees are spread out
in four distribution centers.
We work with approximately 4,000
libraries in North America.
Globally we have 8,000 book
suppliers that send books to us.
And we're taking those books
and either reselling them online
on one of the 30
different marketplaces
that we sell through.
Anytime we sell a book
on BetterWorldBooks.com,
we're donating a book.
So it's kind of like
Tom's Shoes.
It's a book for book program.
And if we can't donate the book,
we're going to keep the book
out of the landfill
and recycle it.
So at any given point,
we've got 8 million books
for sale on our website.
We're processing about
a million books a week
from those 8,000
supply partners.
And we're doing everything
that we can
to increase the availability
of books globally
and we're just very
thankful to be here today.
>> Joshua Cramer:
Well, thanks Dustin.
And just to throw
another question your way.
You know with all of
your diverse experiences
across the world, are there any
stories from the book giveaways
or anything that you would want
to share with the group today?
>> Dustin Holland: Sure.
We have a lot of stories
as you can imagine.
I've been with the
company about 15 years.
Some of those stories
if I shared them I
would get in trouble.
When I first started
with the company,
none of us were married.
None of us had kids.
And thankfully, a lot of us
are married now and have kids
and have calmed down
a little bit.
But a lot of great stories
over the years but probably one
of my most recent favorites
is a book mobile that --
Better World Books is
a for-profit company
but we had a supporter
of the company
that donated a book mobile
to us about a year ago.
So through this book
mobile, we've been able to go
out into the community and
we show up at a school,
prescheduled visits, and kids
come out from the classroom.
They board the book mobile.
We call it Wordsworth
[phonetic].
Holds about 3500 books.
And the kids get on the book
mobile and they can pick
as many books as they
want from the book mobile.
So I think we've donated
a lot of books to a lot
of organizations
around the world
but actually doing it ourselves
with the book mobile has kind
of made it a little more
tangible to us as opposed
to us donating, you know,
hundreds of thousands of books
to an organization and
we're not on the ground
to help distribute those books.
So to be able to see the kids
jump for joy and trade books
and sometimes they
fight over books,
it's really, really powerful.
>> Joshua Cramer: Thank you.
For the rest or panel, if you
could share what you think
or some of what you think
might be the biggest mistakes
that we could make along
the way as we try to develop
and sustain readers
across a lifetime
and I mean I could
start with you, Chris.
Maybe we'll just
come back this way.
>> Christopher Lehman: Sure.
I mean I guess one -- I was
kind of touching on in terms
of pedagogy but it can really
be for anyone is trying
to over prescribe --
okay I'll [inaudible] --
I'll go for it this way.
I think there's two extremes.
One is to over prescribe
the sorts of reading
that we'd expect secondary
students to do instead
of allowing choice
but there's --
perhaps that is equally
dangerous
but also a consideration is
that as students are aging
and the amount of complexity
and texts that are around them,
we also have to pair
that independent reading
and lots more reading time
with really thoughtful
responsive instruction as well.
So that our students are --
we're meeting them
where they are in terms
of their literacy development
but then we're adding
instruction on top of that.
As I think was mentioned earlier
today, one thing that plays
out across the entire U.S.
when it comes K12 education is
really a student's reading level
becomes the ceiling for
which they will perform
on standardized tests.
And these aren't just
tests of literacy.
These are tests in
social studies and science
and other content areas too
because every test is
ultimately a test of reading.
Can you read the instructions?
Can you read through it?
So a student who is reading far
below grade level is not going
to pass most tests.
They will perform far
below grade level.
Students that are approaching
grade level as readers tend
to approach grade
levels as readers.
You can give students --
you can do running records
or give them some sort
of reading assessment just
before a standardized assessment
and the two will line up.
What becomes more of a challenge
is as students are then reading
at or above grade level, that
becomes kind of the opportunity
but it's then their ability to
think critically on top of that
that becomes equally important.
So I think one challenge
is not --
one, finding the right
balance between those two.
Like providing expert
instruction while not
over prescribing it.
And then just to briefly say,
I think the other is not
providing enough opportunity
for educators and in a
larger community conversation
in literacy as well
to really collaborate
and communicate together.
We know that increasingly
the amount of PD dollars,
professional development dollars
but just the amount of time
that educators have during the
day to collaborate and talk
about instruction in many
districts just increasingly
shrinks as money gets
put in other places.
So creating that
time to communicate
and collaborate together which
when I think about the variety
of partnerships and
organizations here to also think
about ways that you
can invite educators
from a school that's local
to where ever your
organization operates
to be a part of that as well.
Educators are in this
field because they care
so deeply about your kids.
They will show up
at the laundromat.
They will go wherever
you invite them to go
with almost no pay,
if no pay at all.
They just need the
invitation and to really know
that that opportunity is
going to help their kids.
Educators, we call our students
kids because they are our kids.
We really feel that
way about them.
So I think providing more
opportunities for collaboration
with your local schools
and educators within it.
If we don't do that as the
problem, if we do it supports.
>> Joshua Cramer: Thanks, Chris.
Louise? Mike?
Things to add about
mistakes that we could make.
>> Louise Baigelman: Sure.
Yes. I think right alongside
kind of over prescribing
that one of the mistakes
that we can make
and that well intentioned
parents
and educators sometimes
mistakes is over judging
around what students
are reading.
So when we talk about choice
which again we've talked
about a lot, it has to be
real, authentic choice.
It can't be, you know, choice
but between these two books
or it has to be non-fiction.
It really needs to be rigorous
at exactly your level or above.
You know we -- or even
format or the type
of thing you're reading.
Is that really something
you think,
you know, that you should read?
I think that we have a tendency
to push towards certain types
of books or certain
types of contents
and that's not a bad angle
but for students especially
in the teen, kind of middle
school, high school range
where judgment is a
very big part of life,
having it be really
open around, you know,
whether it's graphic novels
or comic books as we talked
about earlier or cookbooks if
you love food or blog posts
if that's something that --
we talk about as Story Shares
is any reading is good reading.
And so audio books.
You know reading is about
making meaning from text.
So if you really struggle
with the text piece audio books
are a great place to start.
Using that as a point
of entry as a hook
so that the student
can feel connected
to reading whatever the
format, whatever the topic.
And then you can scaffold up
there and move towards kind
of the goal of whatever
higher level content is.
I think that, kind of, we have
to avoid too much judgment
when really encouraging
students to engage with reading
and find a point of
connection with it.
>> Mike McGuffee: I think
I'll build off of that.
The -- I think the biggest
mistake that's going
on right now is we have a one
dimensional model of reading
in our educational system.
And it's around proficiency.
And I love the work of
Richard Ryan and Ed Deecy.
They're two psychologists that
have self determination theory.
And in their theory, they think
that what we're intrinsically
motivated to be is competent
at what we do, whatever it is,
autonomy is important,
and relatedness.
So competence, autonomy,
If we had those three dimensions
in our literacy thinking
in schools, we would
value autonomy a lot more
and what they argue is that
when you have an over dominance
of one thing, you can
thwart the others.
I think that's what's happening
because we have this, again,
if we don't have this
purpose that we want kids
to be avid readers
and lifelong readers,
then we can start focusing
on grade level reading.
Over dominance one dimension
of proficiency can cause
autonomy to be thwarted.
It can also cause
relatedness to be thwarted.
Lois said it earlier about
that reading is about identity.
It's about agency.
Those are -- that's
autonomy and relatedness.
And so I think we as educators,
we tend to talk to each other
and I think we need to branch
out and start looking at some
of these psychologists
and the systems thinkers
that can help us kind
of maybe reframe this.
>> Christopher Lehman:
Can we also add to that?
So if third grade
guarantee is a mistake
that many states are
implementing the expectation
that by third grade, you
have to read a certain way
or you're held back or lots
of terrible things happen
to you along those same lines.
>> Joshua Cramer: Absolutely.
I have to admit there's
a little bit of bias
in this next question
coming from NCFL
but I think it's very
relevant for a lot
of folks who are listening in.
What is your advice --
and I guess, Dustin,
we'll start with you.
What's your advice for parents
and caregivers in their quest
to develop and sustain
readers across the lifetime?
>> Dustin Holland:
Go to the library.
It's as easy as that.
>> Joshua Cramer:
You guys hear that?
[Laughter] All right.
All right.
I have no other way to put this
but you have a big book
sitting underneath your seat.
[Laughter] And since you're
talking about libraries,
I feel like you should tell us
a little bit about that book.
>> Dustin Holland: Sure.
And speaking of libraries
and literacy organizations,
I know another thing that
groups are always looking
for and that's money.
So our grant program
is open right now.
We're accepting applications
through May 31st.
We've got $100,000 of grant
funding available right now
and our literacy
council will be going
through those applications right
after the period
closes May 31st.
So please go
to cares.betterworldbooks.com
to check it out.
In the meantime, I did speaking
of access, one of the things
that we're very proud
of is keeping books
in the reuse cycle.
And --
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.